[Musique]
juste en fils bonjour vous êtes maire du
lourd est conseiller territorial bonjour
je n'étais pas un film bonjour bonjour
non vous vous présentez pour la deuxième
fois aux législatives
quelles sont vos motivations
ben écoute et effectivement vous avez
raison c'est ma deuxième présentation à
l'élection
pour les législatives donc 2010 cette
première présentation 2022 seconde
présentation les motifs les motivations
elles sont simples c'est que je suis
constante dans mon engagement pour mon
territoire et mon engagement n'est pas
opportuniste il c'est un engagement dans
lequel je m'inscris de manière durable à
la fois dans ma ville et puis sur
l'ensemble de la circonscription puisque
comme vous le savez je suis également
conseiller communautaire et conseiller
territorial est un élu qui est engagé
l'état la fois pour sa ville mais
également pour son pays
alors justement vous êtes vous l'avez
rappelé conseiller territorial maire
vous êtes
au cap nord également est ce que ce
n'est pas une course aux mandats alors
non pas du tout je ne conçois pas la
politique que comme une course aux
mandats au contraire je pense que
simplement ça me permet d'avoir à la
fois je précise qu'à cap non je n'ai pas
de responsabilité particulière sinon que
d'être simples conseillers
communautaires j'ai fait le choix de
laisser l'un de mes délégué
de la ville du lorrain a siégé au bureau
de cap nord dont je suis un simple élus
communautaires et je précisais donc tout
à l'heure que ça me permet d'avoir une
vision comme je l'expliquais à la fois
micro donc à l'échelle du territoire et
puis une vision macro à l'échelle de la
martinique et de pouvoir être à chaque
fois pertinent dans les choix et les
décisions qui sont prises en fonction de
l'institution à laquelle on siège mais
je précise vraiment que et puis quand on
est au service de son pays on n'est pas
au service de son pays à moitié on l'est
totalement
vous allez devoir faire un choix et le
soin sa ponte seriez obligés de si vous
êtes élu de laisser la mairie c'est un
choix facile qu'on fait mais c'est ce
que je viens d'expliquer c'est à dire
que la politique c'est pas c'est quand
on fait un choix on également dans le
choix on fait un sacrifice ce sacrifice
là comme je l'expliqué j'ai des élus qui
travaillent avec moi le conquérir j'ai
des élus qui travaillent avec moi j'ai
une équipe qui est fidèle depuis 2014 et
depuis 2008 autant pour moi avec
laquelle j'ai on a mis en place un
schéma directeur de développement de la
ville et malgré le fait que je sois
candidat aux élections législatives
je continue avec eux à travailler sur
les dossiers de même atteint avec
d'autres responsabilités si ceux ci
aient le choix de des électeurs de la
circonscription
je continuerai donc à être un élu je
dirais un conseiller municipal de base
mais qui va continuer à travailler parce
que ça n'est pas parce qu'on n'a pas de
responsabilité hôte qu'il 9 qu'il faut
s'arrêter je continuerai bien au
contraire à travailler je suis un
militant et un militant ne s'arrête
jamais de travailler on vous a connu
autant macro distendues mais les 17 vous
ne vous ne l'est plus expliquez nous
pourquoi pour une raison simple comme
j'ai été macro nist comme 70% des
martiniquais en 2017 qui ont voté pour
lui au second tour ça c'est une première
chose mais ce qui avait motivé mon choix
en 2010 est je le rappelle pour ceux qui
l'oublient et c'est que emmanuel macron
était membre du gouvernement de françois
hollande et j'ai toujours eu des mots
mon engagement politique une affinité
beaucoup plus proche du parti socialiste
plus que mes premiers combats politiques
je les ai mené avec simeon salpêtrière
qui était socialiste le président
françois hollande ne se présentant pas
aux élections il y a eu donc un de ses
ministres candidats j'ai soutenu ce
ministre là par contre chemin faisant
les décisions qui ont été prises par ce
ministre quitte donc devenu candidat et
puis président étaient les décisions
qu'il laissait perplexe la première
décision c'était la suppression des
contrats aidés la seconde la suppression
de l'isf et du ciel qui à mon avis les
deux dernières qui sont les plus
terribles
c'est là l'action qui a été menée sur la
pl en particulier pour ce qui concerne
les étudiants moi je crois que c'était
la décision qui qui était la décision de
trop et qui a fait que j'ai je dirais
pris mes distances avec ce gouvernement
là qui aujourd'hui me semble davantage
être un gouvernement et qui prend des
décisions de qui relèverait de ce qu'on
appellerait la droite qu'un gouvernement
de gauche alors vous êtes candidat donc
sur la circonscription nord quelle
serait la priorité de sur cette
circonscription c'est une circo c'est
une circonscription que je connais
parfaitement bien parce que comme je
voulais expliqué j j ai exercé des
responsabilités j'étais président de la
commission développement économique à
cap nord dont je la connais à la fois
sous l'angle social sous l'angle
économique mais également sous l'angle
environnemental l'une des préoccupations
que nous avons dans le nord c'est la
question du désert médical je pense
qu'il y avait urgence aujourd'hui
notamment sur l'hôpital du lou rey qui
est un nécessaire donc il faut lui
donner une offre de soins et renforcer
élevés sur la côte caraïbe également
faire en sorte que bien que
l'établissement de soins notamment sur
saint pierre car mes puisse nous
permettre de je dirais offrir et
augmenter cette offre de soins nous
avons une problématique environnementale
qui est catastrophique c'est celle du
chlordécone les quatre candidates du
grand ensemble et nous sommes unis pour
compass les à l'assemblée nationale pour
que ce travail là soit fait et par
conséquent j'ai cité 2 deux éléments
importants mais il y en a bien d'autres
et si vous m'interrogez je vous
répondrai justin pamphile voilà c'était
cinq minutes je vous remercie
[Musique]